Tired of telling Codex, "Use this style, do it this way,"
at the start of every chat?
Here's how to make Codex remember your preferences permanently with one file,
so it gets it right without you repeating yourself.
So say Codex just made this for me.
I like how it turned out, this layout, this style.
Normally, I'd have to describe this all over again next time,
but instead, I'm just going to tell it to remember it.
From now on, whenever I ask for a landing page and I don't specify styling,
please use this exact format and style.
Remember this going forward.
That's it.
I just told it, "Remember this going forward."
And what it's actually doing behind the scenes,
it's writing this into a file on your computer called agents.md.
That's your manual memory file.
Anything you specifically ask it to remember goes in here.
Now, let's paste another prompt to open the agents.md.
Open the agents.md file for this project and show me what's in it.
See that?
It literally wrote down what I like, the format, the style, everything,
in plain text right here in this file.
And here's the best part.
This isn't just for one chat.
Every new chat you start, Codex reads this file first,
so it already knows your preferences before you even ask.
And you don't only have to ask the agent to update it,
you can literally open this file yourself and edit it directly like a notepad.
Add rules, remove ones you don't like anymore, whatever you want.
This file is basically your agent's permanent instruction manual
for how you like things done.
So next time, instead of repeating yourself, just say, "Remember this,
check your agents.md file,"and boom, your agent never forgets your style again.
Try it out and let me know how it goes.